greetings everybody
uh
welcome to our last lecture of the term
we have survived
a
a semester online in 18404
and um
we are going to
conclude our last topic today which is
interactive proof systems
that we started last time
and um
with the big well
the um
uh the big theorem of interactive proof
systems is that um i p equals p space
and we're going to give the main idea
for that in a slightly weaker uh
theorem
um as we'll see
so
uh why don't we jump in um so today's uh
we have been doing interactive proofs we
gave an example
of showing that
the graph isomorphism problem
the complement of that is an ip as you i
hope you remember we had those
that interaction with approver and
verifier we're going to go through it
quickly
not that protocol but just this setup
and
then we're gonna
uh finish uh by showing that this
numbersat problem is an ip
and conclude that cohen p
is a subset of ip
all right so
let's go for it um
[Music]
yes
um
so just remember
interactive proof systems there were
these two parties the approver and the
verifier the approver has unlimited
computational ability um i kind of
uh
you know
uh
modeled that as a an army of students
perhaps who are uh have who can um
where we where we don't uh
they can work all night they can use
computational resources
and um the prover however we're not
gonna measure the computational power of
the approver that's unlimited
and so the approver can do things like
find certificates
it can test whether things are
satisfiable
it can
factor numbers we don't care they can do
whatever we'd like and there's no charge
for the provers computational um demands
okay so the setup we had was the
approver and the verifier both see the
input they exchange a polynomial number
of messages and then the verifier
accepts or rejects
and
we
had this notion of
the
probability that the verifier ends up
accepting when paired with a particular
prover
and we what we want is that for strings
in a language
that probability should be high for some
prover and for strings not in the
language that prover that probability
should be low no matter what the prover
does so there's nothing the prover can
do
um and the way it kind of suggests that
any particular any prover but whatever
the provers
strategy um cannot make the verifier
accept with high probability just
doesn't have enough information or it
doesn't it's just not able to make the
verifier accept with high probability
um
i i uh you know you might think of the
prover is trying to make the verifier
accept so you know that pete tilda is a
crooked prover i didn't i don't think
that that was went down very well with
everybody so i i have it here another
way of looking at it maybe it looks a
little bit more like np
here
where
um
ip is the collection of languages where
there's a verifier just like we had you
can think of np as a having a verifier
which can check certificates
here the prover is going to be like the
certificate so that for strings in the
language there's approver
which can interact with the verifier and
make it accept with high probability and
you're not in the language there is no
prover which can interact with the
verifier and make the verifier accept
with even more than low probability
what's important is this gap just like
with bpp
between acceptance or rejection
and that gap is there
because we want to be able to use the
amplification lemma and if there was no
gap then you wouldn't be able to amplify
and make a make the probability of
acceptance extremely high when you want
it to be in the language when you're in
the language and extremely low when
you're not in the language um
okay so i hope that gives you
you know refreshes your memory as to how
that works we're gonna um
walk ourselves through the um
uh
um
[Music]
well
through that
what we did last time but
let's set the stage for that so the
surprising theorem as i mentioned is
that i p equals p space
um
one direction of that is a fairly
standard simulation
you if with p space
you can basically work your way through
the tree of possibilities for an
interactive proof
uh protocol
and you can calculate the probability
that the verifier would end up accepting
if you had the best possible approver
that would make try to make the verifier
accept and you can just do that
calculation it's in the book
um you're not going to be responsible
for knowing that actually we haven't
covered it in lecture but it's not very
hard
um a little technical i suppose
the other direction is the interesting
one and that's the direction we're going
to be moving toward today we won't quite
get there
um but the way it works is that uh to
show that everything in p space which is
kind of amazing um is contained with an
ip so everything in p space can be done
in i with an interactive proof system
and the way that is done is by using a
piece based complete problem tqbf and
showing that that problem itself is an
ip uh but we we we're not going to prove
that um that would be sort of the next
thing we would prove if we had a little
bit more time but um
we're going to be satisfied with just
the somewhat weaker but very similar
statement that
cohenp
cohen p is contained in ip here
again still very surprising
because you have to be able to show for
example that a formula is not
satisfiable with approver how can
approver convince a verifier that a
formula is not satisfiable um
you know the showing that it is
satisfiable you just give the
certificate which is the satisfying
assignment but how do you show
something's not satisfiable
it's unexpected
um and the proof of that is pretty much
similar slightly is one kind of
technical point which we don't have to
get into so it's slightly easier but
very much in the same spirit
so remember this number set problem
is
you're given a formula and a number and
the that number is supposed to be
exactly the number of satisfying
assignments of the formula um
so in particular formula is
unsatisfiable
then it would be paired with the number
zero
and that's why
uh the number set problem is cohen p
hard
because you can easily reduce the
unsatisfiable
unsatisfiability
to number set and unsatisfiability is
uh coinp complete
okay so remember we introduced this
notation last time this is going to be
critical for understanding this proof so
let's go through it once again
so if you have some formula
what i like to do is preset some of the
variables of that formula so that's
going to be a formula on m variables x1
to xm
and i'd like to
preset
the first i
variables
to certain to zeros or ones as i wish
um
so i'm going to indicate that by
fee
with 0
means i'm setting x1 to 0 and the rest
of the variables remain variables
um
and
more generally fee of
five i values a one to a i which are
going to to start off with are going to
be just zeros and ones just boolean
values that's going to be the formula
with those first
x1 to set to a1
dot dot x i set to ai
for those
i
constants
um which are zeros and ones um i'm going
to call those presets because we're
presetting some of the values of the
some of the variables in the formula and
the rest of the variables we're going to
leave as variables so we get a new
formula on fewer variables by doing this
pre-setting process
and we're going to get to do the same
thing in terms of counting the number of
satisfying assignments
so
remember the notation number
fee is the number of satisfying
assignments
number fee with a preset of zero is the
number of satisfying assignments when
you've set x1 to zero
and
number fee of a1 to ai is where you set
the first i variables to those i values
and then you're going to
look at the
number of satisfying assignments with
those presets in mind okay so
there were two facts i'm going to call
them identities because we're going to
um
rely on those and we're going to
actually extend those to the non-boolean
case as we'll see shortly
so um these two identities say that um
uh
first of all
if i preset
i i think the understanding the first
one is clear just by thinking about it
in the case where
i equals zero
so
this is the case where the number of
satisfying assignments
altogether
is the number of satisfying assignments
when i've set x1 to 0 plus the number of
satisfying assignments when i've set x1
to 1.
and this just generalizes that when i
look at
having already preset the first i
variables
so if i preset the first i variables
to these i values
that the number of satisfying
assignments i get there is the number of
satisfying assignments i get with those
presets plus the next variable being set
either to zero or to one and then you
add those up the same idea
and lastly if i set all of the variables
to values so i have no variables left
and i look at the number of satisfying
assignments consistent with that fully
set
um
variables so there's no variables left
everything is set everything is preset
that's just whether or not those values
have satisfied the formula already or
not so this is going to be equal to zero
or one the number of consistent
satisfying assignments with those m
presets where m is the number of
variables is just whether those m
values satisfy the formula which case i
get a one or they don't satisfy
the formula in which case i get a zero
okay
critical to understand these in the
boolean case because we're going to
generalize this to the non-boolean case
and it's going to be just more abstract
the formulas are going to look the same
but we're going to have to um kind of
we're going to lose the intuition that
those things correspond to satisfying
assignments
or counting the number of satisfying
assignments
all right let's have a quick check in
here
um
so let's we're just going to do an
example
to hope to
you know nail this in this idea
so here's a particular formula fee
um
and now remember number fee
is the number of satisfying assignments
a fee
the number of satisfying assignments
where i've set x1 to 0 and so on
okay so just and here i'm really kind of
giving you two options
in in each row for the value
now you have to check all that are true
so it's really going to be one at most
one per row presumably
um
all right let's see how if your file if
you're with me here
so the number of satisfying assignments
uh for
uh
altogether well there are two ways of
satisfying this formula
either um this is really like exclusive
or um so either x1 is 1 x2 is 0 or x1 is
0 and x2 is 1.
so one of the value variables has to be
true the other one has to be false and
then you're going to end up satisfying
both clauses as you can easily see
um so
b is b is correct
in the first line
now if i'm going to already commit to
saying the first variable is set to zero
now how many satisfying assignments can
there be
well the second variable just has to be
set to one in order to satisfy
so now there's going to be only one
satisfying assignment
consistent with setting the first
variable to zero
now if i set the both variable both
variables to zero now how many
satisfying assignments
can there be consistent with that
assignment they can be zero because
um
if uh
in order to satisfy this formula one of
the variables has to be zero the other
one has to be one if i'm presetting them
both to zero there's not going to be any
satisfying assignments because zero zero
does not satisfy the formula
okay apologies for messing up that uh
uh
checking on the last day oh well um
all right
let's get let
let's first go over the
um
uh
the protocol we
attempted
for number sat
uh last week
um on thursday
okay
so
we're given the input
the formula
and a k
and remember what we want to happen we
want the verifier to end up accepting
with high probability when k is the
correct value
and with low probability when k is the
not c not the correct value
um
now this is going to be as you may
remember from last time
this is going to end up being a flawed
protocol because it's exponential we're
only allowed to be have a polynomial
size protocol
but
um just looking ahead
in this protocol the verifier is going
to end up accepting with probability one
for an honest approver and with
probability zero no matter what the
prover tries to do so for any prover um
the probability the verifier can cannot
be made to accept
so this is kind of an extreme case
um
where there's not going to end up being
any probabilities
but it's an exponential protocol so in
that sense it doesn't do what we need so
let's go through it because it really
sets us up
for the
polynomial protocol with the non-boolean
values
all right
so first the prover sends
um let's just
look at it and not rush it
the approver sends um
the
[Music]
number of satisfying assignments
according to the approver
the verifier checks that is equal to k
and i think it's best to understand this
first
with the
case that the input is in the language
so k is correct and we have an honest
prover
and then we'll understand what happens
if k is not in the language
and we'll see that no matter what the
prover tries to do
the verifier is going to end up not
accepting
um and again you know this is just a
setup
for the
real protocol so this is kind of a dopey
protocol you're going to think what what
the world and why am i doing this um
it's not uh
it seems like i'm making something
that's very simple complicated but it's
really just the framework that i'm i'm
putting together because
well you'll see
all right so the proof is going to send
the claim for the number of satisfying
assignments
um which in the honest case
is going to be the correct value the
verifier checks that it matches the
input
now the verifier says well i want to be
convinced that your claim is correct
so the approver is going to
justify that claim
by saying well the total number of
satisfying assignments is whatever it is
a hundred because the number
when i have
x1 set to zero
um is 60 and the number when i have x1
set to 1 is 40. and that adds up to 100
which is what you would need to have
happen
so the verifier checks that the sum is
correct
and then says well now how do i know
those two values are right
so then the approver unpacks it one
level
further so breaks those two down by
uh justifying that fee 0 was correct
that value 60 was correct by saying well
now if i set the next variable x2 to 0
and 1 that's going to have to add up to
v0 so maybe to get 60 i had you know 50
and 10.
and to get 40 for
the
number fee of one
i had 20 and 20.
so these these i have to add up
um
so each level justifies the preceding
level
that's gonna we're gonna have that
happen again
um
now the prover says well i mean i still
don't you know i need to be convinced
you know i don't trust you i need to be
convinced that these values are correct
um
so
uh
level by level the prover is going to be
setting more and more of the variables
in all the possible ways until it gets
down to the very
bottom where it's setting the variables
to in all possible ways so exponentially
many settings here um
and the verifier now checks that the
previous
round was correct so that's where we set
only the first m minus one the very last
variable hadn't yet been set
um so it checks all of those
two to the m minus one possible settings
um
in terms of
the new settings that it got
where we set
those m minus one settings but we
extended it by zero and by one and this
is that same identity that we used from
before
um
and now
now that the proofer has sent all of
those possible values rever the
verifier needs to be sure that those are
still correct but the the thing is is
that at this point to verify those are
all zeros and ones because they all say
whether
that
assignment satisfies the formula or
doesn't satisfy the formula so the
verifier can check those directly
checks each of those
whether just by plugging into the
formula and seeing did does it satisfy
the formula or not so each one of these
is a zero one value which corresponds
supposed to correspond to whether the
formula was satisfied or not
those all
are correct
um
uh
and everything else along the way has
been correct the verifier is going to
accept otherwise if at any point
the ver
one of those checks failed the verifier
is already rejected or at this point it
just rejects
okay so that is the
um
the protocol the exponential protocol
um and
i'd like i i you know
not sure if this is helpful to you or
not but i like to think of it sort of as
a tree of possibilities
um so
uh
these
yellow values are what the prover is
sending so the approver first sends
the number of satisfying assignments all
together the verifier in white is
checking uh is that are they doing these
checks so it checks that it equals k
and then
the prover sends
the next level the verifier checks that
the edition works out then the approver
sends
unpacks it further
assigns values to the first two
variables
and
the verifier checks that just the
assignments to just a single variable
are consistent with that
and so on
and
uh total set assigned all m variables
and then it checks directly with the
formula
now what happens
and here is the case
it's going to be important to understand
both in both here
and in the non-boolean case
what happens if
we had an incorrect value for the input
and what i want to show you is that the
prover is going to
you know i want to show you that the
verifier is going to end up rejecting in
this case
um
with certainty
later on it's just going to reject with
high probability
but for this protocol it's going to
accept with certainty um
and why is that because
uh
first of all if if the prover
if if k was wrong
so i'm indicating the wrong value is in
red
if if if k was wrong so it did not equal
the number of satisfying assignments
if the approver sends the correct value
the premier is just going to be going to
say it doesn't match up i reject right
away
so what is what can the proverb possibly
do
to prevent the verifier from accepting
you're going to see that there's nothing
it can do
but later on there's a chance that the
proverb can get lucky but here there's
nothing you can do let's say let's let's
try to
humor me
and see that what
let's approve prover try to manage
to
uh keep the verifier going as long as
possible
so the approver in order to prevent the
verifier from ejecting at the beginning
would have to lie
about the number of satisfying
assignments
but then
the approver is going to say well okay
you know uh you know
if you you know you're claiming there's
only 99
satisfying assignments proverb doesn't
know what the right real answer is but
the you know the we know it was a
hundred let's say
but let's say you know we k was equal to
99
the approver claimed it's 99 now um
and so the
uh the verifier says okay well it's 99
convince me of that so now the approver
is going to have to say the number
satisfying assignments for zero and the
number of satisfying assignments for one
they have to add up
at least one of those has to be wrong
because you can't have the two correct
values adding up to the to the lot to
the to to the false value
so a lie here
has to yield a lie in at least one of
those two places
and then
a lie there is going to have to yield a
lie in one of those two places just like
you know each lie kind of forces more
lies you know as you know you're trying
to lie the story gets more and more
complicated
in order to try to justify all this
um and so in the end you're going to get
an inequality and the verifier is going
to end up rejecting
somewhere along the line there's going
to have to be an inequality if not along
the way then at the very end when the
verifier does the check itself
because
one of those if you trace that down
there's going to be lies and lies and
lies and then there's going to be
a
at the very bottom one of these values
is going to be wrong
and when the verifier checks them all
it's going to find out that there is
an inequality there and so one of those
checks is going to fail
okay so um
uh
so i'm getting one question here why is
this any better than just checking all
possible assignments without approval
you know i yeah
it isn't
the only reason i'm doing this is to get
us ready
for the
um
arithmetized product
protocol
where we have non-boolean values coming
in
okay so with questions on this i think
it's important to
um
understand this one
don't understand don't ask the question
why the why is just going to be we are
getting ourselves ready for something
later which you don't haven't you don't
know yet
but i just unders i want you to
understand it for what it is
even if it seems unnecessarily
complicated
okay so let's keep going
so how we're going to fix that protocol
so it's not exponential so again here is
a picture of that exponential protocol
and
you know we have that exponential blow
up occurring because at every stage each
value is going to be justified in terms
of two values
at the next stage
so it's going to be
an exponential
exponentially many values after a while
so instead we're going to try to justify
each value here in terms of just a
single value at the next stage
but you know it's not going to be good
enough just to pick either the zero or
the one at random
um because it might be
each there might be just a single course
of lies um going through here
and
the only way to k would you you would be
to catch that would be to guess
correctly at each stage which was which
was the lie and then you would catch it
at the end
um if you're just going to be randomly
picking zeros and ones
um
you're not going to have a high
probability of catching the prover when
it's uh when it's lying and so
um that's not going to be good enough
you you want
you know the the input might be
the wrong value and you might have
approver which is just has one path of
lies
um
and then your probability you would
still have a high probability of
accepting
in that case even though the input was
wrong that's not what you want for the
when you have the the input is wrong you
have to have only a tiny chance a very
small chance of accepting
um so the way we're going to achieve
that is by having these
instead of picking a zero or one for the
values of
uh for these random values we're going
to have non-boolean assignments to the
variables
and we have to make sense of that
and we've already seen an example of
that it's going to be very much the same
um
all right we are we on all we are are we
all
together here
so this is a
a place where we could try um
uh if you have a question we can try to
um
answer that
um are we good
let's keep moving
okay so how we going to arithmetize
boolean formulas it's again the same
idea we had before simulating hands and
orders with plus and times
so we had this from before same exact
picture
actually it's even simpler because now
we're going to be using the true
simulation of or instead of some kind of
a
special case simulation of war in terms
of which we had in the branching program
case
so these
faithfully
do what and and or does when you plug in
zero for false and one for true
so that means that we can take an entire
formula
and arithmetize it the formula built out
of ands and ors and negations
and you're going to get a polynomial
that comes out
um
and that polynomial what's going to be
important for us is not going to be of
extremely high degree
the actual degree is going to be at most
the length of the formula in terms of
the number of symbols it has you can
check that on your own you can
but for now you can just trust me
the degree of the polynomial
because it only goes up during the um
goes up during the multiplications but
the the degree doesn't become too big
um
uh
okay
so
and we're going to be doing and i don't
want this to be a confusing issue here
we're going to be doing but
you know we have to
be
correct um i don't want to be cheating
here so all of the arithmetic is going
to be done in a field
so um
we have to
uh do plus and times mod some
uh number which is gonna turns out needs
to be a prime number for reasons i'm not
gonna get into um but it doesn't really
matter it's just modular arithmetic and
that's one thing that enables us to pick
random values in a natural way because
there's only finitely very many values
in the field and so you're just going to
pick one at random
but here
we want to be able to represent
we it's it's going to be more important
for us to have a larger field because we
want to be able to represent in the
number of satisfying assignments which
can be a number between 0 and 2 to the m
so we have to have a field which has at
least 2 to the m elements in it so that
we we can in a sensible way write down
those numbers um
let's not get caught up with that but um
we can try to answer those questions
offline if you want um
but just think about it for this first
pass we're doing the arithmetic mod sum
prime
okay
so now
we have the same notion as of presets as
we had before
so if we have a formula
and we preset some of the values
but now those values may be non-boolean
values
we may be setting plugging in values for
the formula
not just zeros and ones but we might be
plugging in sevens or 20 23s or whatever
and you know the formula is gonna
you know in order to
have a value a meaning to that we're
gonna treat that formula as the
polynomial from the arithmetization
and just plug in those values into the
polynomial and see what the polynomial
does for you
so here we're going to be presetting
some of the values of the formula like
we did before
and he now we're going to it's going to
be the same thing but now in the
polynomial we're going to be
pre-assigning some of the values
of the variables
to these a's
which from the field
and the remaining variables are going to
stay as unset
um
now we have to give an interpretation
now he is
um
so the new polynomial here
okay so i'm getting a question well
maybe i better take this let me just let
me hold off on that for now uh what the
uh degree is um
um
okay
i'll come i'll answer the questions in a
second
so so now remember
from before
number fee
was the number of satisfying assignments
when i preset the first
i values
it no longer makes sense to talk about
satisfying assignments because these
values may no longer be booleans
so i'm going to have to
write this
formally
um
as
i'm going to plug in those values
those i values for the first i variables
and the remaining
variables
which i have not set i'm going to assign
them to zeros and ones in all possible
ways only to zeros and ones
because what i want to have you know you
might think well why you know why not we
why aren't we assigning these to other
values in the field well because what
i'm aiming at
is that if i were to plug in
zeros and ones at this point into the
polynomial
i'm supposed to get exactly the same
values as i had before because i'm
simulating ands and ors
so i'm just extending
the um the definition the the the the
evaluation into a new realm but i
shouldn't change the values on the old
boolean realm
so i'm going to be adding up
the unassigned the unset variables in
all possible boolean ways
and the first i values could be
non-boolean values okay so you have to
just to accept this as an abstract
notion
um
no longer has an interpretation as
satisfying assignments
okay so as i said what's important is
that for if i if i happen to put boolean
values in now
then
uh fee and number fee
get give the same values as they would
have before
because the polynomial
acts
identically to the formula on boolean
values
okay so this is what i'm repeating what
i said and there's another point that
isn't that's also you know you have to
check
which is that
the identities that we had earlier
that connected up what happens when i
set the first i values
and and i set the first i plus 1 values
those still hold
so
if i set the first i values now to
possibly non-boolean
some non-boolean assignment
that's what i get when i extend
those values um
to one more
a variable being assigned but i just
need to assign that variable to zero and
to one and add those up because of the
way i've defined things over here
so i've uh assigned those variables
you know i i to zeros the unset
variables to zeros and ones you know
when i'm defining the um the number fee
uh function
okay so
and then lastly when i assign everything
now to possibly non-boolean val values
that's going to be there's no longer
anything to add up so i'm going to get
exactly the same
as i got from before when i
so assigning number fee of totally
preset input it's the same as fee with a
totally preset input
okay because in that case there are no
variables left to add up over so uh
there's just one just i just get one
single
uh my sum has just one element in it
okay um
so uh
i'm getting i got a question here for
earlier what happened to the degrees of
the polynomials
uh
well the degree of number fee
is going to be at most the degree of fee
because i'm just adding things up and
addition doesn't change degrees
um
as i preset values
the number of variables goes down but
the degree may not necessarily go down
so the question was i got is the new are
the new polynomials
having lower degrees not necessarily
they have fewer variables
but not a smaller degree
okay so let's do this check it let's see
if that
now again this is i think i have messed
up on this so uh
well
there's one of these that's
does it
i i i i'll give it away in part there's
only one of them that was true anyway so
you can check the one that's true
according to the way we've we've defined
it
okay so this is a little bit of a trick
question here um as i'll explain but
there's only one of them that's
faithfully does the arithmetization as
i've described on this page
and that's the one you should check
okay so um
remember here over here this is the
formula
this is the recipe for how i'm doing the
arithmetization
of this this whole
process here
so one of these lines
one of these
a b or c corresponds to doing that
okay
i'm going to close this down so are we
all in
yeah
so a is the correct answer
um
a does the arithmetization
according to the recipe that i just
described
because if you look at
x1 or x2 you can just look check it in
the very first um
part of the uh
the polynomial
x1 or x2 well it's x1 plus x2 minus the
product x1 x2 so you can just see it
right there the others don't have that
um and the similarly for
x1
bar and x2 bar it becomes 1 minus x1 1
minus x2 and then the product of those
so a is pretty straightforward as the
arithmetization of phi
now in fact any of those would
would work i don't want to confuse you
here but any of those would have worked
because they all agree on the boolean
assignment and that's all that really
matters
um
so if you have any
all i care about is that they agree the
formula agrees with the polynomial in
the boolean cases and these all happen
to agree on zeros and ones
not doesn't matter though uh i put those
there just in case you you tried it by
just substitution of zeros and ones in
you might you might have picked the
wrong thing
um
okay so let's
uh let's take a break here
and then we will um
see about how to go about fixing the
protocol
um after the break uh
all right
so now also happy to take any questions
we haven't really done a whole lot we
basically this has all been review
um of
what we did last time um
but um let me start the
uh
timer
um
and then uh
but feel free to ask questions it's
the setup is
i'll tell you where we're going
this whole proof
really comes down to understanding one
line
which is going to be
in the second half
um
so i'm really kind of
this is all big set up here
to get you ready to be able to
understand that one i'll tell you when
it's coming so you know
you won't you won't have to uh worry
that you'll miss it but it's a that line
is is not easy to understand so i think
it's important to get all of the
framework
and all of the um
uh the context all set up for you so
then you can understand that line and
and hopefully
you know you see that line and
understand it
okay so
uh
the important fact
um
okay so let's go back you wanted to see
the important fact um
uh
[Music]
okay
um
so this is what i was saying before
the
if i plug in boolean values
into the arithmetization
i get the same exact thing as i would
have if i applied the boolean operations
before i did the arithmetization
so
plus and times in the arithmetization
give a faithful
simulation
of and and or according to these
uh little formulas
that's that's all i'm saying
with this and so
if i plug in
boolean values for the a's
um
[Music]
i get exactly the same as i would have
gotten before i did the arithmetization
because the arithmetization is a
faithful simulation
i'm should i also say it let's see um
what does the or rule now
why does the or rule now contain the
minus a b term while the previous
instance of arithmetization didn't
because why
remember in the case of branching
programs we didn't need the minus a b
term
um over here
and that was because we could argue that
it was a disjoint or
um in the case of the branching programs
i don't want to get confusing by trying
to explain why that was
but
in that earlier case
we never had took an or of two ones
it was an or of zero zero
possibly
zero one or possibly one zero and so
therefore we never had to deal with the
case when we had an or of a one one
and here we can have that
so we have to subtract off that a b term
because otherwise we'd have
if we just had a plus b
then when the one one case we would end
up with a two
and that would not be a faithful
stimulation of the or operation because
one or one should be just one not two
so a good this is a good question here
do all the numbers need to be zeros and
ones i'm not sure how negation would
work would work with larger numbers
so this is
um the negation is just you just blindly
follow it even though we're going to be
plugging in non-boolean values
um
[Music]
you know it's gonna be one minus a seven
so you're gonna get minus six you have
to do that mod p so whatever mod q so
whatever whatever that value you get but
um
you can no longer think about it as
negation in the in the in the former
sense
now it just becomes a formal thing um
you're you're just plugging along doing
what the polynomial says numbers are
coming out you think you know this is
just nonsense but the thing is it's
going to have a meaning that's going to
be useful to us that's that's what this
protocol is going to show
yeah so um you can't think about it as
negation anymore it's just the negation
becomes one minus x in the power in the
arithmetized world and you just have to
live with that
let's see um
okay uh
another question here
if all the fee are equivalent for
boolean inputs in the in the check-in um
so this is back into this check-in here
so if all of the
uh
p
yeah you know so the question is why
if they're all equivalent in the boolean
case
uh why is only a correct um
because
this is i define piece of fee in a
particular way
and so this was the value you got if you
follow the way i define piece of piece
of fee the others would work
they just weren't the way i defined it
um
okay uh
any other questions here we should
probably move on
okay can arithmetization be used in
other contexts um
uh
i often i don't know
i there are these two cases where
arithmetization works whether there are
other cases too i'm actually not sure
okay so let's move on
so
uh
our our but our timer is up
the candle is burned down
okay so this was um okay here we go
this is the real protocol
um
so
i'm going to present it to you the way i
did before let's think about it with the
case
first where the input is in the language
and we have an honest brewer
um
so
we start off the same way
the approver sends
fee
it sends number fee which in the old
sense was the number of satisfying
assignments it actually still is because
you know since we're not presetting
anything there's no non-booleans
um in the picture yet so this is going
to be the same value as before
the verifier checks that k equals number
phase so you have to that's why we have
to have the big enough field there so
that we can um
represent numbers up to
the number of potential numbers
satisfying assignments but that's a side
note
so but anyway p sends this is exactly
what we did before no change
the number of satisfying assignments
feel like
now let's just see let's remember and
this is this is one of those cases where
not having a big blackboard
is hampers us
so i'm just going to remind you what we
did last time but i'm going to change
this so remember before p said sent
an unpacked at one level
sent the number of satisfying
assignments said number
uh fee of zero a number fee of one and
then v did that check to justify the
previous value which the verifier
doesn't necessarily trust
okay
fasten your seat belts everybody this is
the whole proof in the next line
okay
so but it's a doozy
um
all right
is going to send
phi of z
as a polynomial in z
it's going to send just a single object
but that object is an entire polynomial
and the way it's going to send that
is by sending the coefficients of that
polynomial
okay so
let's
uh
let's um
that statement
um
so first of all
um
let's understand the value of doing that
so if i can send the entire polynomial
fee sub z represent that as a polynomial
i can plug in 0 and 1 into that
polynomial
and allow me allow the verifier to do
the check that it needs to do
to con to
um
demonstrate
that
uh
number fee is correct
so it's going to check that number fee
is
a
number fee of zero plus number fee of
one
but instead of getting those values
directly from the prover
it's going to get take that polynomial
it got and evaluate that polynomial at
zero and one
okay
so let and just to remember
let's go back
and remember how we defined
uh defined uh number fee
to make sure that we understand what it
means to have a polynomial here
so remember here we're just taking the
very first value
you could put you are okay with putting
a constant 0 or 1 and then adding up
over all possible ex
extensions
all possible boolean extensions to that
um and maybe it's okay to put in a
non-boolean value here like seven
and now you take the remaining variables
and it and assign them zeros and ones
and all possibilities and add it up
now i'm going to do something even a
little wilder i'm going to put in a
variable
for a1
some
you know symbolic
if you want symbolic
value so i'm going to put in a value z
for a1 so now i plug in z for a1 here
and a2 through am are going to be zeros
and ones in all possible ways
so i just get a polynomial in z
the other variables have been get
assigned and added up over the various
boolean assignments and now i get some
polynomial so i get some expression in z
that's just going to be a single
variable polynomial
okay you
whose degree is it going to be at most
the degree
of number fee
so it's degree is not going to be too
big
um so it sends the coefficient so the
degree of that is not too big so there
are not too many coefficients to send
um
so the coefficients are in terms of the
xi's no i'm not sure what the mean the
coefficients are not in terms the x i's
are gone at this point
the x i's we've added up the x i's being
assigned to zeros and ones in all
possible ways
so there are no other variables left
there's only z
um so i'm gonna
do the same protocol in a more pictorial
way in a minute um
so you're gonna see this whole thing
twice
uh but try to get it you'll have two
chances to get this try to get it
you know try hard each time
um
so it's got sensi as a polynomial in z
now that's going to be enough for me to
figure out which number fee of zero and
number fee is of one is because i plug
it in
for zero and one for for z
but now i can
figure out what
number fee of two is also because i can
plug two in for z or number fee of seven
i plug seven in for z
okay so
let's stop here and let's see on other
other questions so the so
is the size of number fee
i don't understand
the so this question about the size of
number fee
um is it is it 2 to the n
no it's not 2 to the m because the
degree of that polynomial
uh number phi of z
i mean you know it's a very large
expression if you want to initially you
know
yes writing that it's going to be an
exponentially big sum but the
prover adds it all up for you
and you're just going to have
at most a small number of coefficients
because the polynomial is only of a
certain degree
and a polynomial in one variable
of degree d has the most d or d plus one
coefficients to worry about so it's not
that many coefficients as an expression
so um shouldn't the summation take 2 to
the m time
i'm not caring about the prover's time
the prover has a lot of work to do but
the prover
prov sends fee of z
so uh the prover
yes the proofer has a
an exponential job
i don't care
the verifier always needs to be able to
check it in polynomial time and that
checking is gonna well we'll have to see
how does the verifier know that that
polynomial was right
that's a question you may maybe you
should be asking
um
yeah okay i'm getting lots of questions
about how much time the prover needs to
take yeah the proof is going to have to
spend exponential time to figure out
that polynomial but that's all right
we're not we don't care about the
provers time
um
yeah
so the summation here is going to be
adding up polynomials that is correct
i'm happy to spend time because really
here this is the whole proof
you have to understand well we have to
understand why this works but um
we kind of understand half of it because
knowing that polynomial
is
enough
to
you know if you could certify that that
was the correct polynomial
for a
number fee of z
then we can use that polynomial to to
confirm the previous value
what number fee was because you just
plug in zeros and ones for this for z
and you add it up
but now how are we going to justify that
the polynomial is correct because this
looks like even a worse job now we have
a whole bunch of coefficients and have
to make sure all of those coefficients
are right and so instead of just two
values now we have like d values where d
is the degree of that polynomial which
could be at most like
the length of the formula
um
uh
so
here is the next idea
um
so the prover needs to show that phi of
z is correct
okay
um
the way it's going to do that
let's say so even before before we do
that so fee of z
is
going to be some polynomial
um
now the prover may be lying maybe
sending the wrong polynomial
how does the prover convince the
verifier that the power that that
polynomial is the right polynomial
well that seems like a tough job
so what it's going to do is
remember that the
um
there is
so there you know there is
there is a correct polynomial
that you would get by plugging into this
expression for the for the correct value
so there's some correct polynomial the
prover may be sending some some
incorrect polynomial
but now those so now we have the correct
polynomial and the possibly incorrect
polynomial which and the point is those
two can only agree in a small number of
places
by that fact that
we proved a couple of lectures
back
regarding polynomials
so two different polynomials can agree
only rarely
so what we're going to do the way the
prover is going to justify that this
polynomial was the correct one
is by evaluating it at a random place
and then demonstrating that that value
you get is a correct value
if the polynomial was
the wrong polynomial
then evaluating it at a random place is
probably going to disagree with the
correct polynomial at that place because
they can only agree rarely
so
the prover is going to demonstrate that
by
evaluating that polynomial at a random
place
that value you get is going to be the
correct value and it's going to continue
to do that in the way using the same
protocol as we'll see
so that's where we're going so to in
order to show that figure z is correct
the verifier now gets to pick a random
value in the field
and the prover is going to show that
evaluating that polynomial at r1 is
correct
remember this looks a lot like what we
had from before where we were val
showing that number fee of zero is
correct the number fee of one is correct
now we're trying to show that number fee
of r1 this random value from the field
is correct
so
the way we're going to do that is now by
unpacking it
one level down
we're going to be using those identity
that identity
by because
this value here is going to be equal to
um number fee of r1 comma 0 plus number
fee of r1 comma 1.
so the way but we don't want to send
both of those so we're going to send
them combined into a polynomial
of number fee of r1 of z
as a polynomial in z this is the new
polynomial in z
okay
so now
if you understood the previous
line then hopefully this one won't be
too hard to swallow because now we're
going to check
um
the identity but here
by evaluating the polynomial again
but one level
at the next level
okay so this is this is um
uh perhaps a good place to uh
to take questions because this is this
is the heart this is really what i spent
all the time setting things up for so
that you would be ready to get this
thing hopefully without
you know and hopefully get be able to
appreciate it and understand
okay so um
so let's let i'm not getting questions
let's let's move on a little further so
now in order so the pollen again the
approver
has sent this polynomial
at the next in stage two
um
now we the verifier needs to be sure
that that polynomial is correct so it's
going to evaluate
um that polynomial that new polynomial
um
at a random location
um
so by picking a random value r2 in in um
in the field
uh and now it needs to show that this
value is is correct um because if that
polynomial had been the wrong polynomial
it disagreed with the correct polynomial
almost everywhere and by picking a
random place it's probably not going to
be the right value
and we'd s
all of the values have been picked and
so we have one last value um
uh to to select a zero and one this
corresponds to the nth
you know if you it would be great if i
could put both
pictures on um on your screen but i
can't um so this very much corresponds
to what happened in the exponential
protocol but just along you know sort of
this arithmetic arithmetized one single
path
so uh it checks that
the previous
value is is correct
in terms of expanding it with zero and
one but again the zero and one comes
from evaluating the polynomial
um
and now the verifier needs to be
convinced that that polynomial was right
so it picks a random value but now it
doesn't rely on the prover anymore it's
going to see whether that
that assignment
that it gets
by evaluating the polynomial
with that random value rm plugged in is
the same as what i get by evaluating the
polynomial for the
formula itself
that the verifier can do directly
because this is now a polynomial
now just plugging into the formula and
using the arithmetization to get a value
out
okay so this was the last line of the
identity
okay we had those two identity those two
identities so this is the second
identity
and we have to check that this is
correct
okay so
uh so i'm gonna describe show this to
you in a picture
uh
not sure it'll help
if you're if you're
confused but
why don't we take some questions on this
so as i said i'm going to give you two
chances to understand this um because i
know it's tough this is especially with
the constraints of zoom this is a
particularly challenging idea to explain
okay so let's see so the benefit of this
approach is that the
approver only sends one item for each
depth level instead of multiple items
that's right
but that one item is the polynomial
so that that captures all of the values
for the entire field
but taking advantage of the
arithmetization that one polynomial
you know us
has a lot of information in it
and what's nice is that you can check
that polynomial by just evaluating it at
random one random place you can check
that that polynomial is correct
um
okay
um
so where does so i'm getting another
question here
where does this come from here if we
we checks that this here so this
where does this
so you have to look to understand why
where this is coming from you have to
we're at the end round now so you have
to look back like at round two v has to
check that
fee of r1
which comes from the end of the first
round
so this checks that this fee of r1 is
correct because that was where
that was how we justified the polynomial
with just a single variable the the very
first polynomial is correct
you know
a little hard to say but this comes from
the previous round
this this guy here
um
okay so this is the polynomial for the
current round this is the value from the
previous round
all right
more questions
so
so why doesn't this run for exponential
time another question i'm getting
doesn't v need to check twice at each
layer yes
if
the the verifier needs to check
um
gets two values but those two values
come from the one polynomial
so there's no blow up anymore
you know those two values maybe you'll
see it in the picture that i'm going to
show so maybe just hold that question
and maybe this will become clearer in
the in the diagram
so another question does this work
because the polynomial encodes kind of
encodes all the possible values together
i think that's sort of true
that sort of mixes them all together
into one object then you have to check
that one object which can be done with a
sort of random probing of it
um
okay
so so this is another good question that
we'll see
explained in the next slide so
uh so similarly in attempt one the
prover can keep lying by by picking
polynomials
um in rounds one you know by continuing
to pick polynomials by lying about the
polynomials but eventually
it's going to get caught because this
value is going to be the wrong value
you know if the polynomial in the
previous stage and the m minus f
you know if it's a polynomial that the
prover sent in the m state is the wrong
polynomial
then you evaluate it you're going to get
the wrong value
probably
um
and so then that wrong value is not
going to match
the correct value which is you can read
you off yourself by reading the formula
okay i think we should need to move on
to the next slide um
all right
so same proof version two but
looks different um again the input is
that
here's what the approver sends here is
what the verifier sends
i'm gonna i sort of whimsically designed
this as a
uh as a telephone chat where they're
sending each method messages through uh
messaging
okay so the prover sends
uh the
number fee to start off with
and then off on the side these are the
checks that the verifier is going to be
doing
so here
in our first round of the chat
the approver is going to send fee of z
remember
this is just a a polynomial
in not too many coefficients so it's a
polynomial in one variable
the degree is small so there are not too
many coefficients here
you know so this is uh so pretending
this is what it might look like
and then the verify so from that
polynomial the verifier can plug in zero
and one
and see that the adds up
um
now the verifier to check that this
polynomial is correct it picks a random
value to evaluate this polynomial on
um
uh and so now it's going to have to
check that this is correct so this is
not nothing to check you're just writing
this down in anticipation of the next
check
now the prover to justify that
that this value is right
that
that this polynomial is right
so we evaluate okay doesn't say that to
prove in order to check that
this value is right
is going to send the polynomial for the
next level
um
now we can from that we can plug in zero
and one for z
see if that adds up
and now to be sure that this polynomial
is right
um we evaluate it at a random place
calculate that
value
and then um
uh
have to have to see
that
this value is correct
so now we expanded one level down
further we pick a we we take a
polynomial for the next variable
and we
see that it adds up
okay i i'm not i'm not sure what whether
this is helping or not
um but we keep doing that until we get
to the very last round uh where the
prover's sending a polynomial
make sure that this adds up correctly
um
and the verifier
to be see that this polynomial is right
picks a random value
and
uh
evaluates it
and now checks that this agrees with the
formula
because we've now assigned all of the
variables and the then we can then we
can check this number fee directly in
terms of the fee um because they have to
agree
okay
and so the verify would accept if
everything checks out let's see what
happens so this answer will answer some
questions um
why don't i go walk through what happens
if um
the
input was
wrong
and we'll
we'll see how
the verifier
is
likely to catch the approver but not
guaranteed to catch the approver in this
case
um
so
if k was correct the verifier will
accept with the honest prover but if k
was wrong
so i'm going to again indicate the wrong
values in red
um
i'm going to show you that the verifiers
is almost certainly going to accept but
not guaranteed
so uh
did i say that wrong so
if k is wrong the verifier is going to
probably reject but it's not guaranteed
to reject
so um first of all if the
does not lie does not send the wrong
value for a number fee the verifier is
certainly going to reject because it's
not going to be get any quality there
um
so the prover has to lie
you know say
you know um
you know if k was 99 but the real value
was 100 the approver if it says 100 the
verifier is going to reject immediately
so the verifies you know the proof is
going to say well let's let's see what
what the approver can do to make the
verifier
uh
hopefully accept from the approver's
standpoint so the proof is going to send
99.
well the verifier says okay 99 fine uh
convince me so the program now um you
know one of these two has is going to be
wrong
uh has to be because the two correct
values can't add up to the wrong value
so one of these is wrong so that means
the prover had to send the wrong
polynomial
because the correct polynomial would
evaluate the correct answers here so the
prover had to send the wrong polynomial
so now when we evaluate it at a random
place chances are
this is going to be the wrong this is
not going to be the same value that the
correct polynomial would have given you
the prover could get lucky
we could have verified it might have
just happened to pick a place with a
correct polynomial and the incorrect
polynomial agree
and that place the approval think huh
i'm saved
now i can act like the
honest prover from this point on
and you know the verifier will never
catch me
you know i said a little bit analogous
to
the situation maybe
you know
you know i'm trying to see if you really
studied the whole course so i'm giving
you an exam
but by picking sort of random places
there but maybe you just studied
you know a few facts from the from the
course
you might get lucky i might happen to
ask just about those facts
and then you give the appearance of
having studied everything but you really
didn't so here the approver might send
the wrong polynomial but the verifier
just queries that at the place where it
happens to agree with the correct
polynomial and the verb just gets lucky
and the verifier is going to accept in
that case but there are very few of
those
so that's why the prover
is almost certainly to be caught if it
tries to lie
but not guaranteed
um so again so just tracing this down
uh
if this was a lie then one of those two
has to be
a lie so therefore the next polynomial
has to be a lie
and so we continue so then the next
value is almost certainly going to be a
lie not guaranteed and so then one of
those two values
has to be a lot at least one has to be a
lie
therefore the polynomial has to be a lie
and so on
um
uh until
uh you know unless the approver got
lucky along the way somewhere which is
very unlikely even though it has several
opportunities
you know we've arranged ranges so that
the chance of getting lucky is tiny at
each stage so even though he has a few
chances there's still going to be a tiny
chance that you're going to get lucky
somewhere
and so
this is wrong then chances are that's
wrong and so therefore this is going to
be a disagreement and the verifier at
that point
when it doesn't agree it's going to
reject
unless the people got lucky somewhere
along the way which is unlikely
okay
so
uh i don't know if you had
so that's my all i was going to say
about this proof uh i don't know if you
had any questions on it but let's just
see
okay so
[Music]
uh do we have any questions i can answer
how the approver gets
how how does approver get
number how does the prover get
number fee of z
um
so you have to you know why is number
fee of z
have no other variables you have to go
back and look at the the definition of
number fee of number fee of a because
you add up over all the other variables
so now we're pick plugging in instead of
a plugging a variable for that but
you're still adding up over the other
variables so this is a very column this
is a function in just one variable which
is about who can because it's
you know it was original original thing
was a polynomial so so this is also
going to be following
um
i think we're starting to run low on
time so this is our very last check-in
for the semester here so of course
there's one natural question to ask you
all
and for our very last check-in as we're
in our last couple of minutes of the
course or the least of the lectures
does p equal np what do you think
will maybe pb equal np be solved by a
deep learning algorithm or maybe we'll
never prove it
give me your best guess
okay we're
kind of running out of time so let's not
think too hard here
um
another five seconds
all right ending polling
uh i'll share that with you
oh yeah i did share uh so what what do
we get d here
we will prove it in somewhere between 20
and 100 years from now that's the seems
to be the majority opinion
uh
i don't know
i hope it'll be sooner than that
because i'd like to see the answer but
uh we don't know uh
uh
yeah if you can prove peter from np yeah
yeah i'll give you an a plus you won't
have to take the final but you better be
sure you're right
um all right so what that is our quick
review
we finished number sat in ip and
therefore that co-np is a subset of ip
um if you're interested in further
pursuit of this material i got a couple
of questions on that these are some
courses you may want to look at
um
i know i checked with um
ryan williams he's planning to teach
advanced complexity
uh
fall 2021 so um
uh that's we're going to be one the most
natural follow-on subject to this one
is the crypto classes also are kind of
make use of some of the same ideas and
there's of course also randomness
computation that ronit rubenfeld teaches
i don't know if i didn't check with her
i don't sure the next time she's going
to be teaching that
um
and uh
good luck on the final
and best wishes
so um and i'm gonna have office hours so
if you have any questions
uh
you know happy to uh answer those but
otherwise
see you all good luck
thank you for the comments yeah i
enjoyed having you all as students it
was it was uh it was a fun time a lot of
work but it was a fun time
i've always been intrigued by p the p
versus np problem and i proved a kind of
a
i proved the exponential complexity
of computing the parity function
in a certain weak model of computation
so parity function is very obviously
very trivial function
um
but the for the parity function
if you can't count
whatever that means but there's a there
is a model you can kind of set up but
you can't count
then
parity requires exponential complexity
and surprisingly not easy to prove uh
but that's probably the theorem that i'm
most known for
anyway but
that would be a topic for another day
um
another question why not include my
hills the my hill and the road theorem
seems i don't know that's a theorem
about finite automata and all of those
ways of characterizing the regular
languages that seems kind of a tactic
technical theorem i don't don't see much
point in covering it and another
question that
some of my colleagues ask me is why
don't i have rice's theorem which is
sort of provides a kind of a machine for
proving undecidability
and uh
i don't know i think that
you can use rice's theorem without
understanding how to prove
undecidability it becomes sort of uh
it's like a
it's like checking
off checking off a box
checking some boxes and then you get
conclude something's undecidable i'd
rather have somebody
understand it rather than just be able
to use some powerful tool
um
can we understand that proof of the num
the proof about the parity function uh
that i just alluded to
that's super hard
you can
with the knowledge from this class i
think you can um
the the that theorem uh relies on a
certain technique which we didn't cover
uh called the probabilistic method which
is a kind of an amazing method uh not
hard to explain but basically you show
that something exists by showing that
the probability
that a random object has
the property you're looking for is more
than zero
um and so therefore the thing that
you're looking for that has that
property has to exist um
there are lots of examples of that these
days but it's it's kind of an amazing
method so use that method do i think
quantum computing can solve useful
problems beyond the capability of
classical computers
i have no idea whether one can really
build a quantum computer it seems to be
always 20 years off at least to doing
one that factors and i've been literally
uh i remember people 20 years ago saying
it's 20 years off so
uh i don't think it's converging um i
i'm skeptical that they'll ever build a
chronic computer that can factor i'll go
out on a limb and say that
but that's controversial
um
and whether it can solve other useful
problems i'm not sure whether useful
problems are there well i guess they're
simulating quantum systems so maybe that
that might be possible
um
all right i think i'm gonna
i'm gonna end this
now but
thank you everybody take care bye
you